انسحب الاحتلال من مخيم نور شمس بعد ليله
داميه عاشها المخيم ادت لارتقاء عدد من
الشهداء فيما اصيب عدد اخر منهم في هذه
المنطقه نرصد حجم الدمار التي خلفها
الاحتلال نتيجه للجرافات العسكريه التي
اقتحمت هذه المنطقه وعاثت فساد كبير في
هذه الطرقات كما تشاهدون قوات الاحتلال في
ساعات الليله اقتحمت مخيم نور شمس نفذت
عمليه عسكريه قامت بتدمير جدران المنازل
وايضا يعني الطرقات وا قيام وقيامها
بتدمير شبكه ال الكهرباء وايضا الصرف
الصحي والمياه في اطار وفي سبيل سياسه
العقاب الجماعي وزعزعت الحاضنه الشعبيه
للاذ العسكريه في داخل هذا المخيم دمار
كبير في هذه الصوره للبنى التحتيه وايضا
لشبكات الصرف الصحي وشبكات المياه هذه
المنطقه ليست فقط ما قامها او ما دمرها
الاحتلال وانما هناك مناطق عده في هذه
المنطقه وفي مناطق عديده من مخيم نور شمس
قام الاحتلال
بتدميرها بشكل كلي او جزئي عدد من المحال
التجاريه ايضا قام الاحتلال بتخريبها
بالكامل انسحب الاحتلال وترك خلفه عددا من
الشهداء
والاصابات من مخيم نور شمس في مدينه طول
كرم ليث جعار
الجزيره